no no there seemed to be no bounds to
the MINI Countryman zazz are calm and I
hold it now has even more doors more
space and more variability the John
Cooper Works aerodynamic kit includes a
different bumper a different diffuser
and side sills let's see how that works
in conjunction with the high torque
diesel engines the John Cooper Works
aerodynamic package is available with
the most powerful diesel and gasoline
engines we checked out the 105 kilowatt
diesel unit with a torque of 305 Newton
meters it's an efficient option for car
buyers consuming just 4.7 liters of fuel
per 100 kilometers
the aerodynamic kit translates into
enhanced vehicle dynamics and appearance
the countryman SD has a beefier look
thanks to extra elements for the front
apron with aerodynamics spoiler lips the
letter S on the radiator stands for
sport
and that package also includes sporty
elements for the rear apron with an
efficient diffuser they organized the
original mini with a bigger engine is
super stiff this car is a lot sporty-er
but at the same time it's a pretty
comfortable ride and why not in a
countryman that said the suspension
remains on the agile side in typical
mini style this model is a far more
practical value than its brothers
however there's ample room for four
adults in this car the largest mini
inside the only sign of it being the
special John Cooper Works edition is a
plaque that's notes linehalt
kid under sleepin orphan hours although
this is all about the aerodynamic kit
which you only notice visibly from the
outside the countryman offers 350 liters
of cargo room if you need more you can
expand it to a maximum of 1170 litres
you'll find no sloppy styling in this
mini sound workmanship can be found
everywhere the instruments will be a
familiar sight with the big round
speedometer in the center of the
dashboard
that's a loadings one thing that does
bother line hold is all the hard plastic
like it's little brothers the sporting
genes of this maxi mini give it dynamic
handling the 1.4 ton countryman has a
conveniently low center of gravity and
the steering has a more direct feel
giving the car excellent cornering
abilities prices in Germany for the
countryman SD with the John Cooper Works
exterior start at just under 30,000
euros
Spann Whitman you might not associate
the modern upscale Mini with economy but
our test car showed as otherwise the
countryman with John Cooper Works
aerodynamic kit cost ten thousand euros
less than the Edition with the really
big gasoline engine but looks identical
Reinholds only gripe is the hard plastic
on the interior plastic in an arm